- Did you know that there's
a movement right now
to get a woman on the 20 dollar bill?
- I did not know that.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] Quick question for you.
- Okay.
- Who is on the 20 dollar bill?
- Benjamin Franklin.
(buzzer beeps)
- I wouldn't be able to tell you that
until I look at a 20 dollar bill.
- Who is that guy?
- Jackson.
(bell dings)
- Nailed it!
- (snaps fingers) Nailed it!
Do I get the money?
- No.
- Oh.
- His first name's Andrew,
his last name's Jackson.
- He was a general in the,
in one of the, in some war.
(military bugle plays)
- He was a white guy.
He ruled the country for a little bit.
Um, and, yeah, and now he's on our money.
- There's a lot of presidents
who aren't on the 20 dollar bill.
Why him?
- Uh, I guess because
he had a cool hair cut.
- Mm, I couldn't tell ya.
- Well that's a hard one.
I wouldn't know that one.
- I don't think anyone does.
Do you think that it's time
that we had a woman on the 20 dollar bill?
- That would be nice.
Hillary Clinton. (chuckles)
- Honestly, I love Whitney Houston,
I would like to see Whitney Houston on it.
- If I have to say off the top of my head,
I would say Michelle Obama.
- You know what, I would
say Justina Machado.
- Justina Machado?
Who's Justina Machado?
- She played the wife of
Freddie on Six Feet Under.
- [Interviewer] There
is a movement right now
to get a woman on the
20 dollar bill by 2020.
They've nominated four
women to be on the bill.
There is a Cherokee Indian
chief, Wilma Mankiller,
which I think is ironic
and funny and I like that.
- [Woman] Cool!
- [Interviewer] Eleanor Roosevelt.
- [Woman] Oh, okay.
- [Interviewer] Rosa Parks.
- [Woman] Mm-hm.
- [Interviewer] And Harriet Tubman.
- [Woman] Ah, yeah, all
about Harriet Tubman as well.
- [Interviewer] Of the four of them?
- Mm-hm.
I would say Rosa Parks,
Harriet Tubman's definitely
an important choice too,
so either of the two.
- Uh, Eleanor Roosevelt, probably.
- Eleanor Roosevelt.
- Harriet Tubman.
Underground Railroad.
We don't do enough to honor
black people on the bills.
- Probably that Mankiller woman.
Whoever she is.
- Did you say Cicely Tyson?
- Yeah, Andrew Jackson's like the worst!
(laughter)
Trail of Tears, he's a
terrible human being.
Just hated Indians.
(white noise)
(Morse code signals)
(drumroll)
(cymbals clash)
(upbeat swing music)